to kenya now where the runner-up in the
presidential election has confirmed that
he will contest the result raila odinga
called the outcome a travesty and
accused the chairman of the electoral
commission of acting unilaterally and
illegally in declaring william ruto
kenya's next president despite his
strong words odinga urged his supporters
to remain peaceful
the long wait for kenya's election
result is over
but like every presidential outcome in
kenya since 2002 this one too is
disputed
in our view
there's neither a legally and badly
declared winner not a president-elect
mr bukhari's announcement purporting to
announce a winner is a nullity
he acted with
gross impunity and in total disregard of
the constitution and our laws
odinga lost his fifth bid for the top
job
despite the support of his old rival an
outgoing president uhuru kenyatta
people in his stronghold city of kisumu
have mixed feelings about challenging
the results
i think what ryla should do right now
she will go to court
and uh
for them to decide who should become the
president of kenya but as up our views
ryla is the president of kenya okay it
can go to court and we can win
so
but my fear is
the court might order that we go for
re-election which is going still to be
mismanaged like this one
meanwhile ruto supporters are eager for
him to take office soon
since the start of the election it was
very peaceful
as you can see also the atmosphere is
now relaxed and it will continue being
relaxed
because we are expecting our fifth
president to come in anytime yeah
but kenya could face weeks of
uncertainty
and the way forward may ultimately be
decided in court
so another contested election in kenya a
little earlier i spoke to maritime tiger
from the international crisis crisis
group in nairobi i asked him if this is
a setback for kenyan democracy or does
it show that kenyan democracy is
functioning
i would say that it shows kenyan
democracy maturing and institutions are
developing more and more because as i
said in the past when you had disputed
elections you would have immediate
communal clashes
uh the police firing into protesters
this was a very heavily contested
election 14 million people voted the two
top candidates were separated by only
200 000 votes roughly 1.7 percent and
the country still seems calm and very
importantly the institutions are being
asked to upbeat arbitrate the dispute
between the two top candidates so i
would say this is progress for the for
the country uh
elections in the region are almost
always coronations so you don't really
have competition i think competitive
democracy is maturing in kenya and
they're good lessons for the region
you